beautiful thing that they do every year
five days
on somebody else's tab for sure there's
nothing about that that's not fantastic
i love the posters too i'm so welcoming
and five days in vegas yes yes and what
a weekend they're gonna have the
weather's gonna be beautiful perfect
right
and it has been that we're on a trend
lately with gorgeous weather it's so
nice to go out in the parking lot it's
not blazing hot you got your car once
the show ends it is november right yes
we're knocking on the door of
thanksgiving can you believe it yes and
temperatures have been so perfect lately
can we keep that going though so that's
the big question it's been above average
lately we've seen 80s we've come just a
couple digits shy of the actual records
but right now it's just a
picture-perfect day today great shot
there from our tarot camp i just
actually posted this out on social the
sunset because it's been so nice now we
checked in with air quality because i
was kind of concerned since we have a
lot of wind sometimes the particular
matter starts to build up and that's
what we've been seeing so moderate air
quality right now due to the smaller
particulate matter that's soot that's
the exhaust that's on the air right now
because we've got this valley it's a
bowl basically right now carbon and
ozone good air quality though does still
remain in the good range
right now in the mid 70s for centennial
hills along with sky canyon 73 aliante
the east side coming to 82 sunrise manor
79 for whitney ranch in green valley 78
mountains edge and road trench 73 anthem
and mid 70s for henderson will switch up
our neighborhoods so uh nobody is left
out 76 for prompt 71 search light and 83
right now down there for those of you
joining us from wafflin this evening
clear skies here but just the north look
at this
we have that system impacting the
pacific northwest still socked with all
that rain and even some snow in the
cascades and eastern washington the big
roots of idaho there we're dry here
we'll see some clouds increase tonight
seeing them from the northwest right now
but unfortunately those clouds aren't
going to bring us any rainfall this
weekend looking good temperatures will
be in the low 80s for that great
barbecue weather warmest day will be
saturday now sunday we see some changes
we'll see the winds elevate a little bit
a little breezy and then we'll cool off
a little on sunday and that cooling
trend begins sunday and beyond winds
however again are going to stay light
going to stay calm for the next few days
by saturday we see those winds pick up a
little more but like we said the bigger
winds are going to become we think on
sunday
59 degrees tonight overnight mainly
clear and cool 81 for tomorrow still
above average almost 10 degrees above
average here is your eight day forecast
now looking ahead warmest day saturday
like we talked about cooling things off
as we get to next week next week's gonna
be cooler but this weekend a reminder
don't forget to turn back the clocks i
actually was asking if we could play
some share
if we could turn back time oh yeah what
happened but we can't because she did
not share yeah
she didn't get back to us by deadline i
got good news for you whenever chris
matthews does karaoke he always loses
shares i mean we could we could do one
i know i'm putting you on the spot
talking hockey